now we were just talking there about
Labor's there deputy leader Tom Watson
and the review into his position mr.
Watson of course has been an outspoken
critic of the leader Jeremy Corbyn on
both anti-semitism and brekford an
initial plan this week to abolish the
deputy leaders position was if you
believe reports in The Sunday Times
orchestrated by Jeremy Corbyn senior
advisors Kerry Murphy and Seamus Mill
momentum founder John Landsman and
according to The Sunday Times the
general secretary of unite Alembic last
case so mr. McClosky joins us now now
I'm keen to get your reaction to a
brexit and what day Margaret I was
saying but we need to first get to the
bottom of what happened in this attempt
- Tom what's them to get rid of the duck
- leader position no not at all I mean
this is just another fake news I had
nothing to do with it and you not think
about it basically what it is it's just
frustration because you see the deputy
leader of any organisation the prime
role is to assist the leader and
unfortunately Tom gives the impression
that every time he speaks is to
undermine the leader now that
frustration amongst members will
manifest itself and I think that's all
that happened Jeremy Corbyn didn't know
about it I said the first thing about it
was when it broke in the in the media I
knew nothing about it and this is fake
news because obviously the media are
looking for a story is it not more I
mean to be fair to the media I mean you
would it would be strange if we weren't
reporting on this at all no I accept
that but I mean it's gone it's dealt
with in some ways you know it's a good
thing because it demonstrates that that
Jeremy called his leadership he stepped
in he calmed it all down and it's
yesterday's news but the upshot of it is
that there will now be a review into the
position of deputy leader Jeremy Corbyn
who says he wants to people this is all
word there's a constant review of the
structures of the Labour Party laxity -
frankly I am ambivalent about it it
doesn't really matter to me I'm more
concentrated on
leader jeremy corbyn's message and
getting him into number 10 that's what's
important not somewhat while we move on
to other issues I just want to ask you
about one more staffing issue Andrew
Fisher someone who of course was really
at the heart of the team who had a big
role in that election manifesto that did
very well for the Labour Party last time
I think I'm right in saying the only
member from his first leadership
campaign still in that office he's
decided to step down is that loss well
he's not stepping down yeah he's not
leaving us this is another non-story
andrew is a valued member of the team
he's still there he'll be there in the
general election that we're about to go
in to him so he's made it clear that
family commitment is got a young family
and incredibly high-pressured job and he
wants to a better work-life balance good
luck to him but he still widows so it's
not a question of him suddenly resigning
in a fit of pique he still with us he'll
be working in the general election and
he'll be a valuable member of the team I
think Sunday Tong says they got a hold
of a memo where he says I no longer have
faith that we will succeed
he criticizes the lack of
professionalism competence and human
decency
I mean I guess this is fake music again
right I mean the reality is in a
high-pressure job there is always
frustrations and they bubbles to the
surface but well all's I know about
Andrew is he's a very valuable member of
the team and will continue to be well ok
ok now let's talk about praxis
channeling and Labor's position on
brexit is to have a second referendum
but it won't commit to how it can
in that referendum what do you want to
see well that's absolutely correct I
mean the position that Jeremy Corbyn is
laying before a conference this week is
that when he becomes Prime Minister he
will negotiate the best deal possible
and that will respect the 2016
referendum once he negotiates that deal
he will take it back to the people on a
confirmatory vote with remain on the
ballot paper he's also said that labour
would recall their conference to
determine what position the Labour Party
will take in that vote and that's
absolutely correct trade unions do it
every single day we negotiate with an
employer we bring the deal back and we
make a judgment with our shop stewards
normally as to whether we're going to
recommend acceptance or not perfectly
straightforward
absolutely honourable because it is only
Jeremy Corbyn and labour who are
offering the whole nation you've got the
Tories who've dismissed one half of the
nation the Liberal Democrats who've
dismissed the other half of the way
she's only labour trying to heal and
mend our broken nation during this toxic
debate that we've had for two years
well if you're the ones who are trying
to bring everyone together and the
others that just were outriders just
look at the polls and I accept that the
polls are different but there is a clear
concerted lead and it's also clear that
the Lib Dems are making gains on labour
so why is it not that you're not doing
better but Sophie if I take you about
just two years the polls were indicating
that labour would be wiped out and when
the election took place we came within
touching distance of power in fact
commentators like yourself or unanimous
in the view that if sorry if that
election had have taken place an
additional two weeks then labour would
be in power so what happens in the
election is people listen to what labour
has on offer not just brakes if there
are a whole host of issues that have
that ordinary working people everyday
lives investment in their communities
investments in our manufacturing sector
protecting our public services defending
their national health centers given our
children our students from home all of
those issues will be heared by people
and I believe labor
come out of this conference for the
clear brexit policy based on what Jeremy
makes and my appeal to all delegates is
support your leader support the NHC
statements then they will see that labor
is the only party trying to heal a
broken nation we know that Jeremy Piven
is going to come under pressure from
members from them to the cella cabinet
from backbenchers to back a remain
position would it be a mistake
yeah so the reality is if you're gonna
need gold shoes and there is a belief
that Jeremy Corbyn and labor could
negotiate a much much better deal the
best deal from the European Union then
you only make your judgments about what
you should do in the confirmation vote
when you've got that I believe that this
conference will support them of course
there are strong views about me me but
when the arguments are put to conference
on Monday I believe they'll support
Jeremy Corbyn I believe the unions will
and I believe the constituencies would
would it be a betrayal of the many labor
leave voters to take a remain position
well that is precisely why Jeremy Corbyn
is that effectively tries to say look we
have what's your view my view is jeremy
corbyn's view we said in just two years
ago when labor went see to the general
election two years ago
we said we were going to respect the
2016 referendum Corbin has been
consistent in wanting to respond to the
Democratic wishes but of course there
has been a polarization of views and
it's therefore absolutely correct that
we should go back to conformist revolt
we remain on the ballot paper but not
campaign necessarily well that will be
determined when people who look at the
deal I know that there is an attempt to
suggest that this is a fraud sure it's
confusing
it isn't confusing to trade unionists
when I go into an employer to negotiate
a deal I don't say to them well I'm
going to negotiate a deal with you but
whatever you give me I'm going to
campaign against it I wait to see what
the deal is I take you back normally to
my shop stewards which in this case will
be a repo of Labor Party conference and
say what do you think we then make your
decision as to whether we will recommend
that to our members which in this
particularly scenario will be the people
we we know you're close to Jeremy Corbyn
some portray you as a road block to a
more explicitly remain position on the
label it ok I'm really gay that is faith
news and it's nonsense it's it's done to
try and project the image that Jeremy
Corbyn is weak and as influenced by
people I've never met a stronger
individual than Jeremy Corbyn all the
stuff about his age and always looking
about he's already seen off to
conservative prime ministers in David
Cameron and Teresa mang and when we get
a chance in the general election you'll
see a third of January Corbin is his old
man he makes his own decisions more
acoustic which is remarkable he listens
he wants to consult widely he wants to
listen he wants to bring people together
but the idea that anybody any of his
staff or people like me stop him from
doing what he wants is just not true so
what's your message then to people like
any hungry people like Damon got back at
who you just heard from who would like
to remain
well my message is to support the leader
I support the leader we'll see when the
the results of the brexit debate comes
out I went to five Fringe we think
lossless why the support for Jeremy
Corbyn is palpable in this conference
I mean the real challenge is to speak
outside the war know well the real
challenges are speak to the electorate I
accept that but we must go into an
election United and when we have a
policy on braces and Jeremy Corbyn makes
it clear that that is the policy then
that's what leading members of the
Shadow Cabinet should argue for if they
find that they can't argue for it
because they feel strongly well of
course they have that right but they
should step aside they step aside from
the Capitals the Shadow Cabinet which
will become the campus and they can
argue whatever they want but the policy
and my appeal to them to Emily and to
anybody else in support your leader
Emily Thornbury is a fantastic
politician she's been loyal to Jeremy if
we get to a position where Jeremy is
saying let's not make our decision on
how we will campaign until we know what
the deal might appeal to here support
Jeremy and that's my appeal to the whole
of you have an issue then with people
coming out and saying all campaign to
remain whatever happens if they're in
the leadership because of course in in
the situation of the toxic nature where
you know the Tories have dismissed one
half of the country the Liberals of
dismissed the other in order for labour
to get through the message of unity and
healing our nation everybody needs to be
singing from the same hymn sheet now if
the leadership team leaving the cabinet
the Shadow Cabinet soon to be the
cabinet find not difficult then yes they
should step aside and would you blame
them for perhaps of course whether they
the pole laying that some of the people
claim that there's a lack of unity well
obviously at the moment there is
confusion when
leaders say different things that's why
if we get a clear position at this
conference
everybody should commit to it and if
they can't I don't blame them if they
want to step aside from the leadership
role to argue their case God you know I
respect that of course I think but there
has to be one clear message coming from
labor in terms of the leadership on our
policies when we go into an election
just finally would you like to see
private schools first what I like to see
private schools are Wallis I would like
to see better education for ordinary
working people I could take you to
places in inner cities around our nation
where the schooling is appalling I
wouldn't want my children to go there
and it's because of the inequality that
exists in education and the inequality
that exists in our in our society in
general and labor will put that right
the answer to question is yes thank you
very much Len McCluskey